quatre caméras sur des plans fixes c'est
le dispositif utilisé par l'agencé ace
prod pour couvrir le procès du chantage
présumé à la sextape du footballeur
mathieu valbuena ou cinq personnes dont
un autre international français karim
benzema sont appelés à comparaître du 20
au 22 octobre une retransmission
installé depuis la veille comment le
procès de karim benzema s'ouvre à
versailles donc nous on est mobilisé on
est deux à être mobilisés pendant trois
jours du début du procès jusqu'au
verdict en fait et après on a tout la
désinstallation aussi pour que ballan
dit les gens puissent travailler sans
avoir toutes ces caméras et essai télé
un procès dit médiatique les caméras se
sont installées pour permettre une
retransmission en direct dans une salle
annexe composé de journalistes et toute
personne souhaitant y ont assisté en
fait on n'a pas le droit de faire de la
réalisation dessus parce qu'il faut
surtout pas dénaturé en fait ce qui se
dit et c'est vraiment juste pour rire
comme si les gens étaient dans la salle
en fait pour cette affaire les caméras
vous restez fixe en revanche pour une
autre catégorie de procès une
réalisation et mise en place il ya une
différence avec les procès historique
par exemple ont cours en ce moment v13
donc le procès du bataclan dans ce cadre
là par contre qu'à une réalisation on
est avec un peu plus de caméras il ya
huit caméras la règle de base selon
général on met à l'image la personne qui
parle on essaye de limiter les plans d'
écoute les plans de réaction c'est ce
pro 2 retransmet les audiences dans le
cadre d'un partenariat avec le ministère
de la justice ça fait maintenant ça doit
faire six ans qu'on couvre les procès
dont presque tous les procès historique
alors c'est quoi les procès historique
pas ya effectivement le celui en ce
moment c'est v13 avant il y avait le
procès de charlie hebdo encore avant on
a fait les procès sur le génocide
rwandais et après au niveau partie
médiatique ont amené à faire des et
procès d'un tueur en série 2 ou de stars
alors là il ya benzema on a fait le
procès à l'idée en tant que prestataire
audiovisuel du ministère il arrive à
lagence de couvrir parfois cinq procès
en même temps à travers la france la
société est composée de huit salariés
permanents est une quarantaine
d'intermittent